bill maher who i often describe as a
slow-motion conservative and his moment
of truth will come
this coming november when we'll get to
see uh if he's going to be still
supporting democrats and i suspect that
he will unfortunately uh he does get it
on a lot of things he just gets it in
slow motion here he is getting it about
democrats
and then there's abortion
a difficult issue for the democrats to
lose on but they're trying
for decades liberals have said if only
men could get pregnant this wouldn't
even be an issue
and abortion rights are women's rights
well that's wrong now or as the kids say
hold up
when the wokey end of the progressive
spectrum talks about abortion now they
shy away from that word women and prefer
terms like birthing people
or people who menstruate because
somewhere there's a trans man who's
pregnant and i say good for him and i'll
be
and i'll be looking for his story
somewhere in a future issue of ripley's
believe it or not
oh democrats let's take the first
[ __ ] word a human animal understands
mama
and replace it with something best
understood by four trotskyites at
berkeley
[Laughter]
as with all these issues the wavering
voter is saying to her lawyer the
democratic party hey so happy for you
that you have so many other clients
and that you care so much about their
problems and all the pro bono work you
do but you're supposed to be my lawyer
bill once again you're right
you're right but you're right in slow
motion the left has gone completely
bananas so when you talk about the wokey
end as if that has not completely
infected the entire host that is where
your mistake is show me a democrat who
is against seven month abortions
show me a democrat who is against
critical race theory show me a democrat
who's against vocaism i don't mean a
couple pundits like you i mean people
who are in power to actually do anything
about this that is the problem you
refuse yourself bill maher to pull that
lever that emergency lever and get off
the crazy train and yes ally with some
people that you think are religious and
crazy who are defending the world that
you purport you want to live in i saw
this spectacular
twitter thread i had never heard of this
twitter account before but i thought it
so summed up exactly what's going on
here and so much of what i've been
talking about for years and i was elated
because it's like yeah normies regular
people are starting to get what's going
on here you know it's not just you
fringe crazy people watching the reuben
report so this is a twitter account
known as loan rides and let me just read
this thread for you i think it just
really gets to the heart of it you don't
like the decisions yesterday and today
you're really not gonna like the next
part i mean it's your fault but you're
not gonna like it see we were cool with
the status quo yeah we wanted abortion
to go back to the states yeah we wanted
gun rights expanded yeah we wanted our
kids safe from lgbtq indoctrination but
it wasn't enough to fight about
we thought you were like us that we
could argue and make small gains and
lose some ground but everything's
staying fairly level and level-headed
but boy were we wrong because while we
were copacetic and just going along to
get along you were pushing
you pushed abortion from legal safe and
rare in these specific instances you
push now to the point of post-birth
abortion on demand for any reason
you push gun control from background
checks and gun-free zones to now red
flag laws which deny due process
you push the rights of gay marriage to
now the right of lgbtq teachers telling
kindergartners about their sex life and
during all of this you push disagreeing
politically to calling us nazis and
justifying violence against us
justifying harming our families and our
jobs
so now we push back we pushed back with
trump we pushed back with state
legislators we pushed back with school
boards and we haven't even begun to push
back kiddo
we're going to push abortion back to the
rare side in many states we may give you
a time frame like 12 to 15 weeks about
what your beloved other industrialized
nations give we may not we're going to
push back on the lgbtq agenda we're
going to make your lives miserable when
you try to get our kids to question
their gender we're going to remove the
power you think you have and put it in
the hands of parents
you had a chance to call a truce you had
a chance to be in control and happy you
had a chance to just leave us alone you
didn't
you pushed and prodded and provoked and
you're threatening to commit violence
now
good luck with that
there's a saying about the danger of
making people who want to be left alone
get involved you've made us get involved
so all of it from here on out is
squarely on you
enjoy the whirlwind you have so
deservedly reaped
credit
to this anonymous person who put that
thread together isn't that
just it